hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll and today
we're going to talk about reality we
like to think that almost all episodes
of mindscape talk about reality in one
way or another but today we're gonna dig
a little bit more deeply into what it
means for something to be real you know
what that means we're gonna be talking
philosophy as well as science some
things you just know are real tables and
chairs being classic examples of things
you know are real but we could even
question them but there's other
categories where the issue is less clear
our morals real is the ability to make
free choices and to have free will real
in the world
what about numbers what about a perfect
sphere and other mathematical structures
are they real in the same way so today's
guest is James ladyman who is a
philosopher whose work is distinguished
by insisting that philosophy metaphysics
ontology and so forth had better be
informed by our best current scientific
knowledge everyone agrees with this as a
sort of cliche but James really tries to
make it real in his philosophy and one
of the issues that comes up when he try
to do that as a metaphysics
metaphysician they say sorry about that
is one of the things about science is
that it keeps changing our idea of what
is really real right Aristotle had some
idea of what reality is Newton had a
different idea Einstein had a different
idea Schrodinger had yet a different
idea how can you hope to have any
purchase on the idea of what is real if
the scientific stuff of which the world
is made keeps changing as our
understanding improves so James is
champion an idea called structural
realism that it's the patterns the
structures that relate different things
in the world that really matter that are
real not the actual stuff out of which
it's made maybe someday we'll understand
what that stuff is perfectly but the
patterns between different objects
remain in good shape ease even as you
make a transition from Newtonian physics
to relativity and so forth there are
very plausibly down-to-earth
consequences of a view like this one of
the other things that James has been
working on is the idea of complexity and
complex structures and whether there is
something truly new
comes into being when simple pieces come
together to form something complex this
is an issue of Abby's philosophical
relevance but it's also very important
for computer science for biology for
physics and so forth
now I'll be honest this is a
mind-bending episode no doubt about it
so put your thinking caps on and let's
go James lady beam welcome to the
mindscape podcast
thank you sure so just in case we don't
get through all of our many topics to
discuss I want to start with some of the
big picture questions so you're an
expert on metaphysics and philosophy so
tell me what is real well I want to know
whether you mean what is meant by real
or you want an examples of what's real
or what things I think are real that are
controversial
so yeah unless you have some wacky ideas
about examples why don't we give a
definition of what it means for
something to be real in the book I wrote
with Don Ross called everything let's go
we used this idea of Dan Dennett that B
is to be a real pattern okay so that is
a putative definition of what's real and
the story there is something like what's
real is what it's necessary to talk
about if you want to capture information
about the world and in particular
capture it want to make predictions and
explanations so so on that kind of view
it doesn't make any sense to say
something's real but by the way you
can't predict or explain anything with
it okay very good so if you take that
kind of view you're tying reality to a
lot of indispensability
in
predicted explanitory scheme the the the
good thing about that way of thinking
about things is it's it gives a unified
account of reality between common sense
everyday life and science so for example
I was over the tables real because if I
need to talk about it to get by in the
world but I can also say you know the
Andromeda galaxy is real because I need
to talk about it to systematize the
observations I have of the universe now
part of the the criterion is non
redundancy and information efficiency so
I give you an example the reason why
it's good to talk about the table rather
than just the parts of the table is
because if I talked about all the parts
of the table separately it would take me
much longer to say things and make
predictions that if I just talk about
the table as a whole but the reason for
that is because the table hangs together
as a whole and talking about it as n
objects serves the purpose talking about
it as an object serves a purpose
whereas let's do Tom Ross his favorite
example is or used to be the the
compound object of my left earlobe
Miles Davis is lost soul over the
largest elephant in Namibia you you
combine those things and you get no
extra purchase on the world that you
have then you have by talking about that
each of them separately and so for that
reason that's that's wouldn't count as a
bonafide object yeah so there's those
are a separately real thing they're
separately real things but the compound
of them is not a real thing okay whereas
the compound of the parts of the table
is a real thing because they hang
together but roughly speaking any but
but we could put it you know slightly
artificially we could say something like
well you know in order to track the
behavior of the parts of the drug the
behavior of the world you know I talked
about the table because I can move the
table from here to there and all the
parts stay together I can do a kind of
dynamics of the table if I was
interested in rolling the table
the room or something do we worry that
this puts too much emphasis on
usefulness to us human beings right so
that's that's an objection to this so
some people will say look that's just a
histological you're just talking about
what you need to talk about to keep
track of things and that's not the same
thing as what's what's real if my view
would be yes it is that I mean that
whole point of this is to say no but
what we mean by real what what counts as
real is what what we need to talk about
to to track the track of phenomena in
the sense that the notion of reality is
a word that we invented and we're gonna
assign to it meanings that are useful to
us yeah or you could say or you could
say well let's just look at unconscious
examples of what's real and try to
generalize and abstract away a criterion
for being a bogus to abstract away in
virtue of what are we calling those
things real and the thought is well all
the uncontested thought examples satisfy
this criterion and examples that we
don't want to count as real like the one
I just mentioned of the the compound of
the fiel over the solo and the elephant
violate the criterion assume it's doing
a reasonable job with paradigmatic
examples and therefore is useful for
contested examples right and aren't
there people who a little bit more
extremist about this and say that even
things like tables and chairs aren't
real Rock sort of fundamental their
reality is real right so that there are
lots of people who say you you probably
know the quote that's attributed to
Rutherford I think in science there's
those physics and the stamp collecting
yes I know well a colleague of mine has
it on a poster on their door right so
the thought there is something like okay
we want to distinguish between the stuff
which pragmatic
we talked about and the really real
right
I could talk for a while about why I
don't think that's the right way to go
but for the moment I'll just say I
understand that view but I disagree with
it well certainly by the standards you
just set things like tables and chairs
do serve this function we should
definitely call them real yeah I mean
sometimes I find that philosophers will
say I mean a lot of philosophers will
say this right that all that's real is
the fundamental level or the ultimate
building blocks or something and what
I'll say to that is something like this
look I'm interested in the distinction
which we made between unicorns and
horses right if you tell me all this
really real the fundamental building
blocks then I'll just say okay real
Smeal right what I'm interested in is
the distinction that we make in everyday
life and in science between things that
we hypothesize but then decide don't
exist or that people claim exist but we
think there's no evidence for and the
things that we do think exists like
horses and that's the distinction I'm
interested in and that's the distinction
which I think I've got a good grip on if
you talk to me about some putative
fundamental level which nobody has ever
found and we don't have then I'm gonna
say but that's not the distinction that
we're marking with our ordinary talk of
what of reality right according to which
horses a part of reality and unicorns on
but there are let's move on to the more
contentious exempt the more contentious
examples numbers are numbers real good I
mean they're not gonna they're not gonna
fit the real patterns account so we then
have to say okay the real patterns
account is an account of concrete
empirical reality or something you as
well as numbers you could talk about
courage or you know Abscam um yeah
you're not gonna tell me love is not
real James come on you know the three
illusions that human life is based on
short I don't know those the self
freewill and laughs I'm a big fan of all
of those illusions we all are no love is
real but it's not real in the same way
that the horses are I guess and what
we're interested in the book is giving
an account of real that's going to be
applicable to the kind of questions that
people discuss in philosophy of science
when they ask our atoms real how can you
know our tables real as well as atoms so
so good so the real patterns account is
a is a partial account and if you want
to allow the reality of abstract objects
then the criterion is going to have to
be modified so I I'll say something
disjunctive right you you can either say
the real partners account just is what's
real . and all this other stuff is is
not or you can say the real patents
account is a good account of empirical
reality and we have to say something
different about abstractor know my own
view is about numbers is that there's
something misleading about saying that
the number two is real and there's also
something about misleading about saying
the number two is not real I completely
agree with that
so you mentioned by the way the book you
mean the book everything must go with
you and Don Ross yeah right and so I can
I can imagine in the real patterns
account I mean in some sense the number
five or the concept of love dude you
know real patterns they certainly sir
they do explanatory work right if I say
I have five apples people know what that
means it's a meaningful statement right
but it's I think I agree with what
you're saying is that
number-5 doesn't exist in the same sense
that a table exists that doesn't have
this physical reality right I mean it is
that a meaningful distinction yeah
definitely
the stages of mathematical objects is
something that I've thought out for a
very long time it's very close to my
heart and I I don't know what the right
view it okay one thing I do think is
there suck it was less misleading to say
something like there is reality to
mathematics now why is that less
misleading I would say because what that
conveys is something like the thought
that RIA that mathematics is objective
and mind independent or something right
that we don't just get we don't just
make it up right and that that's that is
my view about mathematics but you know
there are lots of people who know a lot
about mathematics who disagree with that
yeah I mean I'm just talking about this
with someone the other evening and I was
saying you know it's really interesting
because I sometimes think oh well my
kind of belief that mathematics is an
objective in reality that we discover
rather than invent is to do with the
fact that you know I went to university
to do pure maths and maths was my kind
of first intellectual love but then
there are people who are much more math
mathematicians than I am who would say
no it's just a formal system I make up
some rules and then I see what follows
so I mean that's one of the very
interesting things about mathematics is
that within the mathematical community
the Platonism is not plato's by which i
mean the view that maths is it has an
independent reality or something is not
not the dominant view among
mathematicians and that's quite
interesting I mean there are these
people who devote their lives to
studying this subject matter and and I
quite happy with the idea that it's all
in invented or that there isn't a a
reality to it as opposed to just the
playing out of inferences based on it
rules I mean what what what people are
sometimes called if/then ism is a kind
of crude version of this view right yeah
just you just say what what follows if I
think that makes sense to me it might be
a crude version but I think yeah it's a
set of conditional statements right
right but then you know the thing that
people always say in reply to that is
isn't doesn't there seem to be this
sense in which mathematics is is built
into the world because there's this
close connection between this that the
discourse and of abstractions and the
application and reality this is a visit
very difficult yeah I think I didn't
quite get your where you were coming yes
I get that in for mathematical objects
you're a little bit open you can see the
force of arguments on either side and
where did you come down about love and
courage being real Hey accepting that
this is us deciding how to design decide
define in terms rather than us learning
new things about the universe I'll come
down with love and courage being real I
mean when people ask what's real they
often mean you know what are the objects
and philosophers would say something
like you know first-order quantification
well you know love isn't an object but
properties can be real to mmm and I
think talking about characteristics like
that seems to be indispensable and
understanding human beings so so then
where does that bring you down on
freewill being real or not free well now
that's just a
got one because I never really know
what's meant by that I always say to my
students who free well is always
supposed to be problematized by
determinism right and then people say
and you get all this people say stuff
like oh yeah so because we have quantum
mechanics we can have free will or
something right and then I think I read
that's nonsense right because that
because then I think oh right that's
okay then yeah because he said my
actions are the result of some
stochastic event right that doesn't make
me free I want my actions to be caused
yeah I just want them to be caused by my
deliberations right so I suppose my view
of free will is and is this is something
I'm no way an expert and I haven't
thought nearly enough about and you know
this is really impressionistic them but
but I think probably my view is might be
quite close to human kind of
compatibilism that I think I think the
right thing to say is something like I'm
free when I can tell a plausible story
about why I did what I did in terms of
my deliberations and I don't need that
to be something that's outside the
causal structure of reality I mean if
you want to tell me some facts about how
my deliberations are the result of in
the end the physical goings on in my
brain I don't mind I mean as long as the
right thing to say is that I did it
because I decided to rather than someone
held a gun to my head then it would seem
like I was free but I didn't hear that
you know it's really difficult because I
think there are so many levels of
freedom so you know I freely choose but
I have a habit is that free I I freely
choose but I decide very quickly and I'm
I'm clicking on something on a webpage
that's outrageous you know that that
isn't full-blown freedom I think so
maybe the right thing to say about free
will is it's not an all-or-nothing thing
that there are their degrees so in this
book with Don Ross everything must go
you defend a view called structural
realism this is a particular point of
view on what counts as real right how
would you tell us what structural
realism is well structuralism start to
now as a view about about scientific
theories and the reality of the posits
of scientific theories in the light of
the fact that the theories change and
that we've had very good theories which
we now think are not 100% true and we it
wise we will think that not everything
in our current theories is under the
century and so what we want to do is
have a sensible form of realism about
science by sensible meaning a view
that's compatible with with the fact of
theory change and the fact that
sometimes Theory change can be quite
radical in respect of the the
fundamental claims that are made so for
example Newtonian physics says there's
absolute time we don't think there's
absolute time it says that mass is an
intrinsic property of objects we don't
think it is it says that there's
instantaneous action at a distance due
to gravity we don't think there is and
yet I would say there's a kind of
reality to Newtonian forces and you know
of course the great thing about
Newtonian gravitation was it made novel
predictions so if we think that novel
prediction is the reason why we commit
ourselves to what scientific theories
say exists we have to realize that
that's that they can make those
predictions whilst not being a hundred
percent correct now the point of
structure realism is not to say there's
a distinction between structure and
nature and we should believe the
structure nor the nature it's just say
when you look at those cases where we've
abandoned theories what you find is that
you've it's much easier to see the
continuity with our current theories at
the mathematical or structural level
than it is at the level of the
fundamental claims those theories make
about our reality and so there's this so
what reality is might differ from theory
to theory but there's something that is
maintained I would say something like
you know yeah what's maintained are the
real patterns at some level of
approximation right so I mean we were
hearing all about dark matter and the
thing that dark matter is needed for is
is for compatibility with the emergent
correctness of Newton's law of
gravitation right so even in the light
of general relativity we still think
that Newton's law is a low energy limit
that's a real pattern for many practical
purposes within a domain up to some
degree of accuracy so I guess the idea
of structuralism in the most basic level
is is to say well look if you loosen up
a bit about about reality you can
understand how our theories can be
getting things right without getting
everything 100% right and the way I put
it is in terms of the theories capturing
the kind of causal structure of the
world the law like structure the world
I mean philosophers which I would say
the modal structure of the world there's
not a word that many people use what how
would you define it relations of
necessity and possibility between events
so what is necessary what is possible
but it's not necessarily what possible
and and and what what follows give you
know so and you Newtonian mechanics is
going to be just as good at predicting
the return of comments as it was in the
17th 18th centuries
yeah so does that help yeah now well it
helps but it leaves me with this with
this question because I get the
usefulness or the attractiveness of
structural realism to help us maintain
belief that older theories that have
since been superseded nevertheless
captured some aspect of reality right
and it's the structures that it were
being captured but is it just the
structures is that really all there is
to reality the relations between
different things or is there some thing
or set of things even if we don't know
what that set is that we will label as
real things right you see if you take
the real patterns view then things are
kind of ways of describing the structure
and and if they're you know if they're
no if there are no patterns there's no
point talking about the thing so it's
kind of like the the pattern is primary
that the thing is is the way of
identifying the pattern the way of just
talking about it one of the thoughts of
structuralism is that we have this
object property way of thinking but our
physical theories are not just our
physical theories now I mean many
theories theories in economics there is
in mathematical biology are really
easily translatable into object property
talk right and and one of the thoughts
behind structuralism is at least the way
I think about structuralism and I think
Dom does and I think David Wallace
thinks this way is a kind of
mathematical representation in his
primary and we shouldn't expect that we
can translate our best theories without
residue out of that mathematical
representation would we go so far I mean
it seems like we're talking about
relations but are reluctant to say that
there exists the things that are being
related these relations I mean you see
what where my issue comes
yeah I mean I suppose I think of I mean
you can't talk about relations without
talk about things that are related
there's a kind of logical point but
whenever you talk about any actual cases
we have of things we find that when you
investigate them a bit further
they are collections of relations among
other things right so you know relations
all the way down well at least maybe
maybe and if maybe then don't assume not
yeah okay it's modally possible
epistemic ly possible yeah for all we
know I mean I guess what we come up
against a lot in science and philosophy
is the sort of unknown limits of of our
cognition and the way we conceptualized
the world to what extent are our
theories based on how the world is and
to what extent are they based on how we
have to think about things right that
probably like the kind of I don't know
if I'm the right to say this but
obviously if you stick my neck out and
say that maybe the basic insight we get
from cans is that there's a possibility
that the way that we conceptualize
things conditions our representations
and that plays a role to some extent as
well as how things are that how the
world is so you know we can't escape our
own cognition and say well you know
suppose I wasn't this contingent being
with it has evolved this limited way of
thinking about things what how would I
think then well I just can't write I am
this contingent being and has these ways
of thinking not a meaningful
counterfactual no so but but it is worth
worth recognizing like what given that
we've reached the level of
education we have we can now see that
maybe we are in that situation maybe our
cognition isn't apt to describe the
fundamental nature of reality as it is
in itself or something and therefore I
think a degree of kind of hedging and
with agnosticism is appropriate here
yeah okay and this whole field this area
in which these conversations take place
is metaphysics right yeah I mean
philosophy of science but I think the
conversations take place within science
itself okay well in fact that's what I
was going to lean in toward because in
your book you sort of talk about
scientific metaphysics yeah well our
books called the subtypes of our book is
metaphysics naturalised right and you
know hard time to conventional what we
call analytic metaphysics yeah which is
not which is a fairly recent I mean the
phenomenon in the way that it's
currently done I guess so can you just
you know for background purposes explain
a little bit the way it's currently done
and what you're reacting against yeah so
what we rapped against is is two things
at least one is a priori kind of first
philosophy approaches that say I don't
need to know about science I'll just
think about the fundamental nature of
reality you using from the armchair
without scientific knowledge right so
for example that we get debates in
metaphysics about you know what would it
whatwhat in virtue of what to some parts
form a whole now I would say well
depends what you're talking about in
virtue of what do cells form an organism
well the the specific nature of the
interactions and relationships between
them that aren't generic are knowable a
pro all right
in virtue of what do if you have never
met an organism or a cell you would not
be able to say why cells formulary right
and if you if you don't know visits you
can't say in virtue of what that atoms
form the table right there are specific
specific to those things how they
interact one of the themes there is that
we point out that in science composition
is dynamical it's not live a static
thing right so there's a kind of image I
don't have all these parts and then they
are a whole for some reason or other
whereas in science like no these parts
are a whole because of how they're
interacting and often what we talk about
is interactions that are taking place in
a very short time and length scales
relative to the scale we're interested
in right and so it can seem like there
are just these parts but they're
actually you know the table is a
dynamical entity right yeah so that's
that's that's an example of the kind of
where you can get into thinking about
reality if you don't pay attention to
science you just think a priori another
thing that we object to is the imposing
of the manifest image on the scientific
image so for example a kind of view of
building blocks or little little
particles bumping into each other which
we would regard it as completely
outdated in the light of physics another
thing we can tell as a quantum mechanics
and because of qualifications and and
you know even before that with field
theory or whatever but but we call that
the domestication of science right so we
say that one thing is ignore science
completely another thing is take science
and then distort it so it fits your
common sense way of thinking about
things and then kind of pretend that
you're talking about the scientific
objects but you're not really because
you're not talking about them as they
are right and I guess you know we have a
positive
of metaphysics which is one that I think
the scientists engage in whether or not
they would call it metaphysics so this
is why I don't think this is just a
philosophical game or activity you know
I think people do it all the time so for
example you wrote a book about it right
what what can we say about the whole of
reality in the line of our knowledge of
physics how does reality how does
reality at the macroscopic level relate
to the microscopic level
how does biology relate to chemistry
relate to physics so what we say is
naturalize metaphysics is the attempt to
say something about the world as a whole
in the light of all the science that we
have it's some and another way of
putting that is to say something like
naturalize metaphysics is about saying
how science as a whole hangs together
it's about the unification of science I
guess so it can't be you see it sounds
like you're arguing that metaphysics
can't really be prior to science because
until we've learned things about how the
world works we have no hope of just a
priori coming up with these relations
but it still adds something to science
because it talks about things that cross
scientific disciplines or transcend them
right and I think the ultimate test is
it needs to contribute actually and you
know this may be unrealistic and
ridiculously ambitious but I think when
we wrote a book we were we were saying
look this should actually help
scientists who are interested in in how
the world is and it should play some
kind of role and if it doesn't we should
stop talking about it but we didn't set
a time limit on that okay that's very
clever you know you often get scientists
actually making metaphysical claims so a
given example and support nurse who was
a president of the Royal Society came
and gave a talk in Bristol he talked
about the five most important ideas in
biology and one of them he said was
biological processes are physical /
chemical process
his example was the discovery that the
fermentation of yeast is oxidation right
that this is is a way of unifying
biology with chemistry it's a way of
understanding biological processes as
nothing that no special added ingredient
no extra mystery just a very complicated
emergent phenomenon that that is
ultimately resulting from chemical
physical processes now that's a
metaphysical claim yeah and his heat but
he didn't come to give it metaphysics
talk he came to tell everyone about
biology and he would regard that as a
biological discovery I I would say and
it's not really from death not at all
mother my idea David Papineau I guess
was a person who learned this from
chronicled how physicalism has a view
about the mind and more generally was a
contingent empirical discovery there was
no reason to think it had to be true a
priori so in the 19th century people
wondered are there special physiological
forces are there special chemical forces
right right now there's nothing crazy
about that I mean April right maybe you
know it just turned out that there was
no need to posit such things we now
understand chemistry in terms of
predominantly electromagnetism so if
you're wanting to do just as to what's
been learned in the history of science
then you need to say well we've learned
this metaphysical thing right which is
about the relationship between chemistry
and physics and that is all by way of
exemplifying why it's not true that
metaphysics is this other thing compared
to science it is sort of connect you
know if
connected to first-order scientific
practice not everybody's scientific
practice lots of scientists don't have
to care about these issues at all but
every now and again they're really
crucial and some scientists think about
them a lot and don't separate thinking
about them from being scientists so I
was very interested at a poster session
last night we're here for those of you
in podcast land at a meeting of the
philosophy of science Association and
there is a poster by a guy who had
surveyed philosophers of science among
other things on the question of you know
what was the biggest challenge or was
the biggest flaw in their field right
now and there were two big things that
people held out as big flaws one was not
enough engagement with science and one
was not enough engagement with
philosophy apparently because they
thought that as philosophers of science
they were you know isolated within their
philosophy departments so how do you
think I mean I think you just said a
little bit about how you think the
relationship should go how do you think
the relationship between philosophy and
science and philosophy of science does
go right now in practice and then do you
see it changing very good question
how it is for me is that I spend more
time engaging with scientists I think
than I do philosophers and I yeah I blow
up the Philosopher's well philosophers
of science and so I would say in my
field as well I mean I think in
philosophy of physics which is the the
main area that I work on as well as kind
of general philosophy of science the
engagement is very close and I think
it's very healthy I see it is probably a
you know going in the right direction as
well I think that more and more phasis
are realizing that the philosophers of
physics know what they're talking about
and they're not doing kind of force not
thinking about physics from a distance a
lot of the young people are
exceptionally good and really
knowledgeable about the physics I mean
some of them
to phd's it's not that unusual that they
have a PhD in finance and a PhD in
philosophy
I think the intellectual standards and
the level of engagement is very high now
of course one still finds the odd
physicist who thinks that philosophers
are idiots who don't know anything about
physics but you in my own institution
I've written papers with physicists I
teach in the physics department as well
as in the flop as well as in the
philosophy department have very good
relations we have lots of joint honours
students so really the interaction is is
strong and I don't think I'm that
unusual in that respect do you think
there's a change over recent years of
the barriers coming down or were they
just less high than I thought
I think the barriers come down a bit I
mean I think when I was learning my
subject it was true then that the
philosophers of physics people like
Michael redhead and Jeremy Butterfield
and Nancy Cartwright were very
knowledgeable about physics right and I
think you can look back now on some of
their work in the foundations of quantum
mechanics and say this was absolutely
top-notch by anyone's standards so I
guess I'm lucky that I absorbed that
culture early on I mean the point about
how a philosophy of science relates to
the rest of philosophy it depends what
part of philosophy you're talking about
I mean I go to seminars in my department
on asset ethics and aesthetics and I'm
interested in in general philosophy but
where I'm less keen on the pure
philosophy is where I think science
bears on it but people are doing it in
ignorance of science and I in those
kinds of areas I'm sympathetic to this
quote that we have in our book from the
philosopher Quine who said philosophy of
science is his philosophy enough now I
had not heard that but I think what he
would say I mean I think every time you
take a piss Tamala G the epistemology is
about knowledge about justification well
in philosophy of science we have people
who study Bayesian ISM and Confirmation
theory and and
statistical methods of inference and so
on and now I think really the idea of
doing epistemology and not engaging with
that kind of work is a bit odd and
likewise with with philosophy of mind I
think come on you know you've got it
you've got to look at cognitive science
why why would you try why would you want
to do philosophy of mind without knowing
about the science of the mind mind work
yeah and if you think about the history
of philosophy I don't think many of the
great philosophers were also great
scientists some of them spent more time
doing science and they did philosophy I
mean our sloth will be an example so I
think you know if you if you reincarnate
it Aristotle or can't or Descartes or
Leibniz they would be they would you the
last things on their reading list would
be pure philosophy right all they would
be wanting to catch up with the
scientific knowledge which has developed
in the last hums of years since they
were alive that that that would they
would be super excited right I mean I
thought that philosophy of science me
this is not quite what coin said but
related the philosophy of science should
be or could be a paradigm for the rest
of the philosophy in the sense that if
there's any one thing that we should be
able to understand at this fundamental
level at science like science is in some
sense so much easier than aesthetics or
ethics right if insight is I mean I get
ethics is political philosophy much too
hard for me I'd much rather do try and
learn quantum field theory than that you
know it's funny when people talk about
science as if there was it was this
thing right whereas it's kind of
everything right I mean what is science
well that includes anthropology and it
includes economics and includes biology
and it includes cosmology you know it's
the study of the world right right now
what's philosophy well it's the attempt
to understand the world isn't it so how
could you really not do philosophy of
science I mean what what
it doesn't really make much sense to me
well good we're on the same side
speaking of which though to shift topics
a little bit but I think there is
continuity here you have a book in
preparation on complex systems which
might be an area of science physics but
also many other sciences are related to
it which is growing in popularity but
perhaps under philosophized is that fair
to say
yeah lucky for me it's under
philosophize because carolyn advisor
with him i've written this book and i
wrote a paper a few years ago called
what is a complex system and it came out
in 2013 there's a lot of citations and I
think part of the reason is because
there just aren't that many papers you
know on that topic but on life I think
it's all great I'd like to think it's
because it's such a brilliant paper but
but I've I think at least part of the
explanation is that there's a people are
crying out for papers like that because
they they want to think about complexity
and complex systems and understand it
yeah that's that is an area that has
been looked at by plenty of other
philosophers of science other than
myself though and so you know there's
lots of other work out there you know
what one can think of new people I mean
early early papers in philosophy of
science by Herbert Simon you know way
back on complex systems more recent work
by people like Bill Bechtel and Michael
straithan's you know other people have
worked on it but it's a great area
because it's it's the area of science
that's I guess giving us most
understanding of of emergence and
emergence is precisely the name for
whatever goes on when we have biology as
well as chemistry as well as physics
so that's exactly what the topic we were
talking about how does science as a
whole relate how do we get higher level
structure out of out of the basics you
know I think that definition of
emergence I never heard that one before
you know the thing that you need to
explain the world where you get biology
and chemistry as well as physics yeah
it's a contentious word right there's
weak emergence and strong emergent don't
you know I mean the problem with the
philosophical literature on the topic is
that they're probably not a month goes
by without somebody doesn't come up with
a new taxonomy of different kinds of
emergent sayings when I wrote the big
picture I was I was warned by some
philosophers but even more sociologists
don't call it emergence because it means
in some subfield exactly the opposite of
what you want it to mean
right there's a form of emergence that I
like and try to promulgate where you
have some microscopic understanding but
then there are ways of looking at the
system from afar where you see a
different kind of behavior that you
might not have noticed but it's still
impaled by the microscopic behavior and
then there's this entirely different
notion of emergence where the
microscopic behavior just doesn't entail
the macroscopic behavior and it's yeah
that's right so not certain that so some
conceptions of emergence there's some
extra magic ingredient that appears yeah
or something I don't know how to make
sense of that the way that I thought
about emergence since working on complex
systems is is exemplified I guess by you
know how and colonies work right no
overall controller but incredible
emergence in the sense that you know the
ants can build bridges and not only that
I mean they can they can decide whether
it's more efficient to build a bridge or
go the long way around right right they
they consider you know well if we go the
long way around that's going to tie up
the ants
who were traveling but if we build a
bridge is gonna tie up amps in being
part of the bridge there's going to be a
trade-off there and they optimize pretty
well and yet no single ant is asking
yourself this question no signal of
court but I say the ants I know and is
asking itself that question so so the
interesting thing is how does this arise
then and the answer is it arises through
interaction and feedback between
individual ants and that's the thing
you've got to understand if you want to
understand emergence and this of course
goes back to Anderson and Moore is
different the importance of interactions
among the parts of a system in giving
rise to the behavior of a whole and in
feedback I think more and more I think
now feedback is the key is key and in
the case of human beings I think we
really want to think hard about the
feedback between ourselves and the
technology we've made in the form of of
smartphones say right where you know you
look anything well 10 years ago people
didn't do everything on smartphones
right now they kind of do why is that
feedback basically until potentially new
kinds of emergent behavior might be
emerging right which which we're saying
yeah and you know feedback is the basis
of our cognition anyway right because
the way that we become conscious self
conscious normal let's say Minds is by
interacting with each other I mean if if
you have a human being doesn't interact
with any other human beings then then
they will not be able to learn language
they aren't you know they won't they
won't have many of the aspects we would
say we were essential to human beings so
what that means is that it's essential
to our natures that we develop in
interaction and what worries me a quite
a lot is
okay so what's gonna happen if that
interaction is with technology what's
going to happen if that interaction is
with an AI systems or robot we then we
become something different you mean yeah
yeah and so is this providing a partial
or a complete answer to the question
raised by the title of your new book
what is a complex system is it all about
feedback and emergence from constituent
parts yeah so what we say I mean what we
say really is you know sometimes the
right answer isn't terribly exciting and
it's if the kind of boring answer right
and and and I think that's actually
often true you know the right answer is
well there are different kinds of
complex system and they have different
features not all of them have all the
features what are your favorite features
that make up a complex system nested
structure robustness of behavioral
structure modularity so that means
[Music]
something like the division of labor
division of function and also your new
kinds of invariants and universality
that come about when you modern systems
as networks or your model of is
information processing systems so is
this some of the examples is this owned
is the aspiration that this would be a
useful contribution of scientific
metaphysics because we're noticing
regularities or universalities between
very different kinds of success and and
the book is not a book primarily for
philosophers I wrote it recurring
advisor as I said she's a mathematician
we started working together when Bristol
opened a center for complexity sciences
I had a graduate program and they wanted
to have component in that program that
just asked the question of what is
complexity the graduates were a
heterogeneous Bunch you know some of
them are working on new cells some of
them are working on the economy some of
them are working on social structures of
one kind of another
and you know all sorts of things and
right from the beginning we were asking
the question is death
what is complexity is there a single
thing is this you know one kind of
cynical view is is something I there's
no such thing as complexity it's just a
buzzword that people use to get grants
because for a period it really was a
fairly big buzzword I think you know
yeah and the view that we may not taking
is a kind of middle view yeah there is
there is a kind of distinctive phenomena
here but there isn't a single thing
called complexity and one of the things
we do in the book is we discuss the
different measures of complexity that
have been proposed in the literature of
which there are many I proposed one okay
it's not in your book that's work but it
might think maybe it's not no but what
we say basically is that each of these
measures is measuring a feature of a
complex system and it's not measuring
complexities per se but give you an
example I mean some of the measures
clearly what they really measure is a
warder of one kind or another right now
order could have been produced by a
central controller and that's not what
we associate with complex systems the
measure itself can't tell you whether
the order that you've got where it came
from it just tells you how much order
there is so for example in imagine a
string of digits yeah you can calculate
well what's the order how you know what
kind of correlations are there at what
length scales in that string for example
but it doesn't tell you where that
string came from but if you know that
that came from a complex system there is
a kind of proxy measure for the
complexity of that system but it's not
measuring complexity and such it's
measuring order produced by a complex
system and is this so what definition of
complexity is this does this have a name
I know that Jim Cott field for example
likes to always stop people when he they
measure complexity and says like which
measure of complexity are you using
right so what we're saying is each of
the measures of complexity is measuring
a feature of complex systems and that's
why there are lots of different measures
so you don't have to choose because if
what you're measuring is something like
the
you know how clicky is the network for
example yeah
you may want to measure that in terms of
the kind of average connectivity of
nodes or something right or the degree
of clustering of nodes or whatever there
are perfect you know there are good
useful measures of such things but if
you were studying a different aspect of
accomplish system you'd be do using a
different measure so you might for
example have a measure of the robustness
of the system so what we're saying is
there are different features that
complex systems have and there are
measures of those features there's no
one true measure of complexity and are
there or should we hope to find laws of
complex systems like we find laws of
thermodynamics or arguably even in
biology I think you get you get things
like power laws that turn up in
different places and you can associate
those with complexity but I don't think
we're going to have something like you
know a law of all complete systems no I
don't think that doesn't make a lot of
sense well we had our symposium that
brought us here we talked about the
notion of fundamentality which is on the
opposite side of complexity in some
sense maybe and you brought up an
interesting issue that in some sense we
talk about the standard model of
particle physics is being very
fundamental right it talks about
elementary particles and so forth but in
a very different sense we talk about
Darwinian evolution natural selection is
also fundamental but the words
fundamental clearly mean something very
very different in those two cases one
means that it you know with
microscopically describes everything
around us the other is it would still
hold true if the microscopic description
of everything around us was utterly
different so there's some robustness
that extends across possible worlds we
could live in so I guess what I'm
getting at for the complex systems could
there be darwin like behavior that you
say once you have a system satisfying
these criteria we can have certain
expectations about how it might be a
good you know if that was a yes that
could be so for example there might be
I guess you could say we'll look some of
the laws in in biology like the price
equation or something you know are just
that right there they're emergent laws
that apply to complex living systems so
yes there could be in that sense yes
there could be but I don't know
I wouldn't say they'd apply to all
complex systems because I'll are kind of
quite liberal view you know a condensed
matter system is a complex system and so
too is the internet and so too is the
economy good and so I've learned also
last night that you're finishing up
another book this one on materialism is
that right and Robin brown and this is
materialism in the sense of the world is
made of matter or not of supernatural
forces it's not about you know you're
greedy and you want to go shopping
because you like money right yeah I mean
lots of philosophers would call it
physicalism these days but we we talk
about materialism just because we think
that the kind of reader that we want to
engage with the book won't know what we
mean if we say physicalism right i mean
i think we really know what you mean if
you say materialism right well they
might they might think they're
interested in materialism even there and
then then they might want to know more
about it whereas if you say physicalism
they might just think what yeah I mean
for your listeners that to clarify
physicalism is just what we say in the
light of the fact that the can kind of
classical early modern conception of
matter is not really apt for
contemporary physics but one of the
things that Robin and I wrote about in a
paper from some years ago was that
there's a kind of negative side to
materialism and a positive side to
materialism and that the positive side
is some claim about you know like all
there is is that the physical or so
everything somehow is ultimately
physical or you know everything emerges
from the physical or what if there's
lots of different versions of it but but
the negative side is
you know no supernatural stuff I guess
and what we're incident doing is is
chronicling the history of those ideas
and also the way that materialists have
been slandered and persecuted by guests
and often you know people will say
things like oh well if you were a
materialist then you must have no
morality or yeah as you said you know if
you're a materialist then you must only
be motivated to pursue you know base
pleasures or something and that's
obviously not correct and actually one
of the things that I've written about
elsewhere is that you know people often
say all scientism this is terrible view
that takes away all the magic from human
beings and therefore somehow it should
is rightly associated with not caring
about them and I just point out that if
you look at the history you find that
the more that we've naturalized our
understanding of the human beings the
more we've been inclined to treat people
humanely so for example if I if I don't
know anything about medicine I might
think that my elderly relative has
suddenly become a horrible person and
when I understand dementia then I'm now
I mean it no necessary connection but
but you know judge it actually
correlates with treating the person more
humanely because you realize no they've
got a degenerative brain disease it's
not their fault that they're now being
really grumpy and angry a lot another
example might be autistic children where
you might you know an old-fashioned view
would be something like oh this kid is
kid clearly just a crazy kid and now a
more humane view is no this child has is
developing differently from how some
other children develop
actually I wouldn't say it's not normal
because it's part of the normal spectrum
of human life behaviors and and cut
there with lots of different kind of
variations among human beings and it's
it's it's normal that some people are on
the autistic spectrum but if you've got
someone who's quite a young child quite
extreme on the autistic spectrum they
may produce behavior which you otherwise
would just think they're just a horrible
kid once you understand that they're
artistic you say oh this child is having
understanding what's going on we need to
communicate them when with them in
special ways and when we do that we're
able to help them develop and be happy
and to interact with them better and so
on so I mean it could take other
examples you know schizophrenia you know
they're not possessed by the devil it's
okay right and so I think that the kind
of materialistic naturalistic way of
understanding human beings actually
correlates with more humane treatments
of what we might call a typical human
psychology and behavior I think this is
a fascinating claim and partly because
on the one hand I'm inclined to agree
and my anecdotal experience lines up
with this that in some sense for example
in situations where people are dying
I've found that atheists natural ists
tend to deal with it better than
religious people sometimes but on the
other hand I also recognize I have a
huge cognitive bias in this particular
area because that's what I think and I
think I want to think that people like
me are you know better equipped to
handle these things so we interesting to
study in some rigorous quantitative way
whether the connection between
materialism or physicalism or naturalism
and humane treatment of other human
beings is in fact causal and and a rock
connection or is just a coincidence yeah
I mean I'm not making that strong a
claim I think that I'm just making the
weaker claim that there's no necessary
connection whatsoever between a kind of
naturalistic view of human beings and a
cold clinical attitude to human being
that's really the point I'm not making
the claim that you know naturaliss and
nicer people than religious people I
mean in fact there's a lot of evidence
that pro-social behavior stock
correlates strongly with with religious
that's true religious belief you know
lots of the very best we know we often
maybe those of us who aren't religious
may forget that actually a lot of the
the the really important charity work
that's done in this world is done by
people with very strong religious
commitment and I I respect people's
religious faith and I don't think that
people who believe in God idiots or
irrational or or anything but I'm just
saying that it's you know it's wrong to
think that if you're a naturalist or
material materialist that means that you
think that human life doesn't matter or
that you were going to somehow be cold
and disregarding of of human being and
it's your book mostly about the
intellectual history of materialism you
said you were doing a lot of work on you
know how people with these views or
treated and so right so yes it's it's a
bit historical and a bit about what
would a viable contemporary form of
physicalism look like mm-hmm and do you
think I mean I've felt myself and again
but I know that I have a bias I'm trying
to be careful on the one hand the
fraction of people who are atheist
naturalist materialist physicalist is
seems to be increasing with time but our
popular social discourse hasn't caught
up in some way right I mean we still
treat atheists that's a little scary you
know on TV or something like that yeah
you know you could look at it this way
you know if you don't believe in
anything supernatural then that means
each of us have got this life and
nothing else and that makes it more
important right
I mean if if I'd been potentially got
the afterlife
then you know not such a big deal if it
doesn't go well for me here right but if
this is it and let let's not talk about
me I mean let's talk about some child
that's born in poverty and destitution
right that if you think that kid has
only got this one life then it matters a
hell of a lot that they are then their
life options are so curtailed and their
life is full of so much suffering and
lack of opportunity you know if you tell
yourself well yeah but don't worry
because their virtuous they'll God will
make up for it later you might you might
be less motivated to do something about
it now you might not be but you might be
well to slightly misuse a phrase you are
preaching to the converted on there I'm
very much in agreement all right James
lead even thanks so much for being on
the path thanks a lot pleasure thank you
very much
[Music]